hey everybody welcome to the stream you
know normally i would start with
um minutes or even a half hour of songs
in various videos but
we just have something so huge that just
went down that i do want to start with
breaking news
uh actor mark hamill of uh
luke skywalker and star wars fame he has
just
followed me on twitter so this is a
david pakman show exclusive
luke skywalker himself is now
in the system and and rumor has it that
they're looking for something completely
off the rails and immoral to do in the
next star wars and he heard our
discounts are so big
it's sort of like you know even even for
darth vader vader it would be low
and so he's exploring just like how big
are the discounts and are they immoral
and maybe that would be what the empire
does that is disgusting to people on the
next episode so big big irony there
about everything that's going on
uh no i'm kind of kidding but that was
cool to see i've been following him for
a really long time
today why are we here today i actually
don't know
oh we're here because we are going to
hear from president joe biden
commemorating the 100th
anniversary of the tulsa race massacre
and he is in tulsa oklahoma i know that
people expecting me to say
tulsa we only do that when we're making
fun of tulsi but
this is actually serious he's in tulsa i
know it's pronounced tulsa
and um that is today and that is
starting momentarily
but i'm glad to have time to chat with
people let's make sure we have audio
here so
so as soon as they go live we will hear
it because i have
so many different things to talk about
so many different things to talk about
now let me say at the top
i don't have any unban requests today
um there's just none so i have no unban
requests
today to adjudicate but i have tons and
tons and tons of different things and i
may even
i may even this is something i'm
thinking about
i may preview for you my uh
just recorded interview with noam
chomsky nobody missed anything it's part
of today's show
which will be out soon it's already out
for members hello
and i'll i'll maybe play a clip we
actually i we actually spoke about
noam chomsky has these historic viral
debates
that you can watch on youtube one with
william f buckley
another one with michelle foucault
there's many of them and we talked about
them and he actually gave us some
anecdotes
um heretofore unknown stories
about the behind the scenes of many of
those debates
and we're going to uh we're going to be
talking about that
i do want to mention to people that we
we did the sort of
soft launch of the second youtube
channel last week
and many of you dumped in some
memberships we're already at 1400
subscribers on the second youtube
channel the first video has been
published we have a nice little
uh top banner um and and that we we now
already have about seven or eight clips
that are going to be published here over
the course of the next week this is
going to be all different content
if you want like a break from politics
this
this channel is going to be and you can
find it at davidpakman.com
pacman live okay that's how you can find
it this channel is going to have
funny moments from streams more you know
mimetic elements
um we've got a brand new garden tour
that's going to be published which i
might even preview
today on stream if we were to get to our
100 member goal
it's going to be a totally different
thing and it'll be way fewer clips so
for people who don't like
i don't know anything um it'll give you
something new to complain about and for
people who like
things it will give you something new to
look at okay i guess that's the
the sort of story um so that's
pacmanlivedavidpakman.compacmanlive
maybe i would even play drums in fact
maybe i will say when we get our first
10 000 subscribers on this new channel
maybe i will i will do a drum cover why
not right
why not i think that that would be a
really really great thing
um what else oh yeah and we also are
tracking
obviously the twitch uh follower numbers
we are working on our first hundred
thousand we seem to have lost some
followers since i went live
some people clearly made very angry by
me going live that's crazy
i thought you were supposed to stream i
thought that was the idea of twitch some
people furious that i started streaming
and they unfollowed but uh we are
working on that as well but very
exciting stuff
with this second youtube channel and
i'll preview
some of the things that are going to be
on there very very soon okay
as we stand by um oh hold on
i want to say thank you to waleeda hc
for the twitch prime sub that's it just
number one
oh and also odw has just subscribed for
eight months and is number two
if you missed yesterday's memorial day
membership discount it's memorial 21
that's the code memorial 21
and then we also have felony 21
now by the way let's talk about felony
21 this is great
um where was hold on a second oh this is
beautiful
so last week we were covering
the america first rally with congressman
gates and greene
and someone actually sent a super chat
let me see if i can put this up on
screen here
somebody sent the super chat to the
right side broadcasting stream
saying you are doing god's work laura
david pakman code felony 21 and she read
it and
she seemed to have no idea what was
going on it's really good so let's check
this out let me make sure i have the
volume right
this is great i love the fact that
everybody went over to the right side
broadcasting stream and just took over
the chat there
let's listen together i said you are
doing god's work laura
david pakman code felony 21.
thank you very much colin yeah um great
message from colin
and he's my official name laura so i
don't know if you mean lawyer trump or
me but i will
take it most of the time i go by liz so
if you didn't know my
official name is laura elizabeth i
should actually go back even a hair
more just so we can really hear the lead
up hold on google play roku
or amazon fire as well as the android
app store
all you have to do is search rsbn for
all of those and it'll
syntactically i never understand what
this woman's talking about pull up super
easy and a great way for you to enjoy
our programming again
we're working towards uh 24-hour
programming here today
dear god imagine that so we're so close
to having that completely nailed down
immediately after today's event oh wait
no it's sorry this is way before it i
got like here it is
there we go i need to go to these events
and broadcast them out for you guys if
you appreciate them if you like them
and you're able please consider donating
looks like we did get a five dollar
donation from colin poole
i said you are doing god's work laura
david pakman code
the only the only super chat is colin
trolling her so that it
ends up on the stream it looks like we
finally got one of these super chats
uh and it's one of our viewers very
nicely done and that type of uh
of of uh what would we call it um
it's it's sort of like ancillary content
or tangential content
that stuff will get featured really
nicely so that was really good
um few super chats the family says did
you like pete buddha budaj when he was
running do you think he is robotic
pete buddha judge was not at the top of
my list but i recognize that he's a very
good
um he's really really good in these
situations like on fox news and others
that we've covered but i wasn't like
supporting
mayor pete david what do you think of
disgrace general fl
flynn and his myanmar alago coup
endorsement
we have a long and wide segment about
that on today's podcast i have a lot to
say about it
pair says feel your live channel added
have some housewarming yes we have a
redirect now set up
the second pacman channel pacman live is
live
at davidpakman.com
pacmanlive we are going uh i have
committed to a
i guess a drum cover at the 10 000
subscriber mark
which is cool um and then pushing for
the first hundred thousand followers
on twitch and unfortunately we've lost
10
during the stream so that's something to
uh to keep in mind
okay next what do i have next
oh thank you to justin andrew watson
as well as uh no just justin andrew
watson for the twitch sub
i will review my latest i just filmed a
garden video
and um i will i will uh release it today
you guys hear that that was weird i will
release that today
if we get our member goal i got somebody
who emailed me angry that i showed my
garden you know i
i always think there's something that
people won't be angry about
there's something that will just be
completely innocuous and someone wrote
to me saying that
it was arrogant for me to waste my
audience's time with my stinkweeds
so so even even something as completely
uninoffensive as just a garden like it's
just vegetables
and somebody said it was pompous and
arrogant of me to show
my stinkweeds to the audience it's
really unbelievable
uh yeah okay
um let's see let's do
oh okay we've gone really strong
now with now with that we've grown our
team from three to four
we are focusing heavily whoa we are
focusing heavily on tick tock
okay we clipped the the segment about a
flat white
and gay semen from last week it got like
40 000 views on tick tock and a ton of
uh duets
or douays as some people call them just
as a reminder this is the clip
here we go in their coffee to make it
taste
good where did that come from gays tend
to love other each other's semen
and it flavors up the coffee they like
the taste of it it flavors it
up okay so as a result
we got so many funny videos that people
did
i'm just gonna show you some of them i
love this this is a whole new
area of content here we go this is gay
semen in their coffee oh hold on this is
way too loud
hold on let's turn it down okay here we
go start
to make it taste good where did that
come from
hello everyone oh my god welcome to
another episode of me blending this
website is toxic you can't even see it i
think it tastes good
where did that come from starbucks use
okay so that's one man it's just really
hard to navigate this crap
um all right let's look at another one
gay semen in their coffee to make it
taste
good
[Music]
going to starbucks happy pride
okay oh my god it just goes on to the
next one um let me just go through a
couple more of these
uses gay semen in their coffee to make
it
taste good is anybody else wondering why
it has to be gay
semen i asked the same question does it
taste different
i asked the exact same question oh my
god
curious now now the audio won't stop all
right so
the the the the interfaces are just
horrible but let's just look at a couple
of others okay
reactions
and in their coffee to make it taste
good
[Laughter]
okay starbucks uses all right
semen in and then one last one these are
just duets done
in reaction to the clip from the last
live stream which got put
on tiktok you know it's it's it's all
derivative content
here we go last one uses gay semen in
their coffee
to make it taste good
starbucks is gay anyway oh my god i
think people get it all right so that's
the
that's the um flat white content from
um from tick tock all right very good
make sure you're following us on tick
tock
a few other super chats coming in
juni says who do you think will be
indicted first rudy giuliani or matt
gates i think gates
i think gates marjorie taylor pacman
says could you sell your coffee at two
million subs
could i sell my car like sell it out or
what
i don't know what that means i do want
to say thank you to steven harvard
stephen harvard just signed up with
coupon code memorial21 at
joinedpakman.com thank you steven
shelby stevens thanks for the website
subscription using coupon
code memorial21 also thank you to nick
martin who just signed up at
joinpacman.com with coupon code
memorial21 lastly thanks to matt
couschwa
for signing up at joinpakman.com using
coupon code
memorial21 that's four
also thank you to chief boris as well as
beatnizzle
and colors atk for the twitch subs
so i've got that out of the way let me
see what else i've got we did our
starbucks clips
i still have my chomsky stuff oh we do
here's a new contest okay we i would
love for people to do
a new channel intro this would be like a
one and a half to
three second video intro which will be
the intro
animated on the new pacman live channel
as many of you know we launched this
channel last week we're working on our
first 2000
subscribers you can find it at
davidpakman.compacmanlive
but here's an opportunity i would love
people to make these these gotta be
quick little intros that we drop in at
the beginning for pacman live
and anything is on the table the more
creative the better
a one and a half to three seconds send
them to info
davidpakman.com we'll do a contest the
audience will vote on an upcoming stream
for the intro video for all of our
new channel clips all right very
exciting stuff
chomsky okay yeah let's do the chomsky
thing so
i interviewed noam chomsky today let me
pull this up
i'm just going to preview this for you
now if you're if you were a member you'd
be able to
already see the bulk of this interview
i'm just going to play a few seconds for
you
and i think i i hope people like this
one of the things we discussed
was his viral debates
uh with michel foucault and william f
buckley
and here is let's see there's a little
preview okay preview of what as a member
you could already have access to
all that is inconceivable today
professor i don't want to keep you too
much longer but i did want to get your
thoughts on
you know some of the debates you
participated in over the years
with william f buckley with foucault
and so many others that still are so
watched
on youtube and other platforms today
and thinking back to them now
what stands out about them what what do
you remember what seems
to you to to be notable about them as as
somebody who participated in them and
was there in the room for many of those
conversations
well they're different
person we were talking about real issues
you can have
an opinion on them but with buckley was
quite different
my impression of buckley was that he was
just a fraud
when he had a nice style
you know he spoke as if he knew what he
was talking about
as soon as you begin you look at the
debate you can see it
as soon as you get into any particular
issue
he quickly changes the subject because
he basically doesn't know anything about
it
he can try to overwhelm you with his uh
rhetorical style and so on i thought he
was all
surfaced in fact you couldn't see it in
the debate
but at the end he was so infuriated
that he he left the studio
screaming at me saying you know
have you back and show you a thing or
two or something like that
that wasn't recorded but my impression
of him was that
he just kept calm and quiet and tried to
talk about him
about issues it would collapse what was
was foucault or are there others that in
thinking back you say
this is someone who challenged me not
just rhetorically but
really substantively this was really
where i was the most challenged
well it was we disagreed on a number of
things
but at least we were talking about real
issues
i should say that there's a little
background to that
foucault i i don't know any any french
who code doesn't speak english but we
spent the afternoon together before the
debate
just walking around the dutch
countryside
partly just because we want to talk to
each other
informally by the way guys i understand
that his
computer kept dinging um
what am i going to do right i mean what
i'm going to do stop you
sir could you get out of your email and
then also like mute this other
i mean you know he what was i going to
do but partly to see if we could get by
with him talking french and me talking
english
and or did we need a translator so we
figured we could
kind of make it with and
we decided to wing it and do it without
a translator which
sort of worked but i should tell you
something else
this sketch didn't show on the
television yeah foucault you know is
totally bold
yeah yeah the moderator fonts elders
very interesting person he was a dutch
anarchist
there was a dutch anarchist movement at
that time which was
doing all sorts of things like by the
way understand that
what he said michel foucault died i
think in 1984
and the debate must have been in the 60s
or 70s he
he's just talking about like the day of
that this must have been what 50 years
ago or something like that and remembers
the moderator and the specifics i mean
it is actually pretty pretty notable
giving lsd to
horses that fancy uh horseshoes so that
they jump all over the place
[Music]
on the way to the studio fonts elders
stopped at his apartment
went upstairs came down he had a bright
red
wig in his hand and through the whole
debate
if you notice closely he was nudging
kuco and saying
put it on put it on
that is an incredible detail
so there it is uh the full conversation
with noam chomsky will be live
um tonight but if you are a member you
can already get access to
the vast majority of it which is a
really great thing all right
very exciting stuff i want to say
welcome to raquel
al hakab who just signed up at join
pacman.com
with the coupon code memorial21 thank
you raquel your new member number 11
today also on twitch
welcome to andrew dale with the twitch
sub as well as
dirt knap tempst chief boris
who else uh
oh wait no chief boris i already thanked
yeah so that's just three putting us at
14
as we stand by here for joe biden
um let me see what else so we did we've
done channel intro
chomsky very good
um
oh yeah who got the first comment
so this is from the new youtube channel
the first comment ever on the channel
was someone named
icydatboy96 got the first
comment ever on the new channel it was
an historic moment
and then snoski got the second one with
damn
beat me to it so to the extent that
that's something to celebrate
those are the people who got the first
comments on the new
youtube channel and new content coming
to that channel i think as soon as
tomorrow probably
i think that i think that's where uh
where things are looking
and i would invite you to head on over
you can go to davidpakman.com
pacman live we dumped in the first 1500
subscribers pretty quickly
and you could be number 15 11
which is great which is fantastic and
make sure of course that you're also
following over
on twitch a really really important
place
to follow hard to imagine really a more
more important place to be following
anybody
a standing by for joe biden oh okay
voicemails yeah let's do voicemails
i have a whole bunch of different
voicemails let me see here um
let's just start going through them so
so-called normal
voicemails let's take a listen hey mr
pacman
sir no big fan anyway uh you you had a
person on yesterday
uh talking about the new york city all
right here's joe biden so let's go we'll
get back to those voicemails
here joe biden in tulsa oklahoma
[Music]
looking light on his feet when i
enrolled
as an undergraduate at the university of
pennsylvania
my grandmother gave me a manuscript
written by her great grandfather jb
stratford
university of pennsylvania here we go my
grandmother
gave me a manuscript written by her
great grandfather
jb stratford it was a memoir
that began with jb's father buying his
own freedom
from enslavement in versailles kentucky
and continued through jb's life as a
successful business owner
and hotelier in tulsa oklahoma
it was by reading this memoir that i
understood
a part of family history that had only
been spoken about in whisper the tulsa
race massacre that had destroyed our
family business
and criminalized our patriarch jb
stratford
educated at oberlin college and
indianapolis law school jb had a hotel
business in tulsa
that would have been worth over 2
million dollars in today's money
his hotel the 54-room stratford hotel
on the historic greenwood avenue was
sacked
and burned to the ground during the
tulsa race massacre of 1921
along with over 30 square blocks of
black owned property
causing him to flee to kansas and later
to chicago
to save his own life
he was falsely indicted for inciting the
riot
by an inflamed white grand jury
for daring to stand up with his
community
to stop a mob from breaking into the
jail
and lynching a black teenager named dick
roman
sparking the backlash which ended in the
grievous massacre
my family worked to get these charges
against jb
dropped posthumously
i know how lucky i am to have this
family history
passed down from generation to
generation
this history was the one thing that they
were not able
to steal from us but as thankful
as i am to know my history
i understand that history has no firm
line
to divide it from the present
just as there are survivors still with
us today
from this tragic event the mentality of
the mob
to declare that there would never again
be another
black wall street in tulsa that
mentality
also still survives in many institutions
and unfortunately in many people's
hearts
today we welcome president joe biden
here
to stand beside us as we continue the
fight
for justice for the survivors and
descendants
of the tulsa massacre he understands
that as a nation we are and we
must be strong enough to confront
the dark periods of our history with a
bold agenda
of equity repair and healing
jb stratfor died without seeing justice
for the crimes against him in his
community
but i am sure we will see justice in my
lifetime
thanks to the efforts of all of you here
joining us today
and now i introduce to you
president joe biden
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i believe i remember roughly a year ago
trump also did something in tulsa
it was completely humiliating as i
recall i believe we covered it
[Music]
well thank you please if you have a seat
sit down
and i got to make one check
[Music]
he's off script
did he say ice cream
[Music]
i just had to make sure the two girls
got ice cream and this was over
i knew i heard ice cream there yeah how
excited you'd be when you're
four five five almost five years old
coming to hear a president speak trump
would have thought that was a 14 year
old he can't tell what
age kids are all that purgatory
lauren thank you for that gracious
introduction
and in case you were wondering i
in delaware we're a small state
we have the eighth largest black
population in america
and we have one of the most talented
members of congress
and so if i didn't walk around and pay
my tribute to
lisa blunt rochester my congresswoman
immediately
how are you rev good to see you
i we've got a distinguished group of
people here and
uh and i want to thank lauren for
sharing
the powerful story and for helping
the country understand what's happening
here and to all the descendants here
today and to the community and
civil rights leaders and members of the
congressional black caucus that are here
thank you for making sure we all
remember
that we never forget you know there's a
verse in
first corinthians that says for now
we see in the mirror dimly but then
face to face now i know in part
then i shall know fully shouldn't it be
one corinthian
i just uh
here in greenwood cultural center and i
want to thank the incredible staff for
hosting us
[Music]
and here i didn't say what my father
insisted on please excuse my back i
apologize
but the tour in the tour i met mother
randall
who's only 56 years old
god lover and mother fletcher who must
be an 80 year old woman i don't know
and her brother her brother van ellis
is 100 years old
[Music]
and he looks like he's 60. thank you for
spending so much time with me
i really mean it it was a great honor a
genuine honor
you are three known remaining survivors
of a story seen in the mirror dimly
but no longer now your story
will be known in full view the events
we speak of today took place 100 years
ago
and yet i'm the first president in 100
years ever to come to tulsa
[Music]
wait now didn't trump go last year i
could have sworn trump went
but to think about it a hundred years
and the first president to be here
during that entire time and in this
place
in this ground to acknowledge the truth
of what took place here for much too
long
the history of what took place here was
told in silence
cloaked in darkness but just because
history is silent
it doesn't mean that it did not take
place
and while darkness can hide much it
erases
nothing it erases nothing
some injustices are so heinous so
horrific so grievous
right trump was there for juneteenth not
the tulsa massacre but it was in tulsa
why
and so it is here only
only with truth can come healing
and justice and repair only with truth
facing it but that isn't enough
first we have to see hear and
give respect to mother randall mother
fletcher
and mr van ellis
and all those lost
so many years ago to all the descendants
of those who suffered
to this community that's why we're here
to shine a light to make sure america
knows the story in full
may 1921
formerly enslaved black people and their
descendants are here in tulsa
a boom town of oil and opportunity and a
new frontier
on the north side across the rail tracks
that divided the city already segregated
by law
they built something of their own
worthy worthy of their talent and their
ambition
greenwood a community a way of life
black doctors and lawyers pastors
teachers
running hospitals law practices
libraries churches
schools black veterans
like the man i've had the privilege of
giving a command coin to
who fought volunteered and fought and
came home and still
faced such prejudice
right
veterans have been back a few years
helping
after win the first world war building a
new life back home
with pride and confidence
we're a mom and there were at the time
mom and plaque
mom and pop black diners grocery stores
barber shops tailors the things that
make up a community
at the dreamland theater a young black
couple holding hands falling in love
friends gathered at music clubs and pool
halls
at the monroe family roller skating rink
visitors staying in hotels like the
stratford
all around black pride shared by the
professional class
and the working class who live together
side by side for blocks on end
mother randall was just six years old
six years old living with her grandma
she said she was lucky to have a home
and toys
and fortunate to live without fear
mother fletcher was seven years old
second of seven children
the youngest being mr van ellis
was just a few months old the children
former sharecroppers when they went to
bed at night in greenwood mother
fletcher says
they fell asleep rich in terms of the
wealth
not real wealth but a different wealth a
wealth in culture
and community and heritage
but one night one night
changed everything everything changed
while green was a was a community to
itself
it was not separated from the outside
it wasn't everyone but there was enough
hate resent resentment and vengeance in
the community
enough people who believed that america
does not belong to everyone
and not everyone is created equal
native americans asian americans
hispanic americans black americans
a belief enforced by law
by badge by hood and by noose
[Music]
that speaks to that
lit diffuse it lit it by the spark that
it provided
a fuse of fury
was an innocent interaction that turned
into an
ins in terrible terrible headline
allegation
of a black male teenager attacking a
white female
teenager a white mob
of a thousand gathered around the
courthouse where the black teenagers
being held
ready to do it still occurred lynch
that young man that night but 75
black men including black veterans
arrived to stand guard
words were exchanged then a scuffle
then a shots fired hell was unleashed
literal hell was unleashed through the
night
and in the morning the mob terrorized
green with torches
and guns shooting at will a mob
tied a black man by the waist to the
back of their truck
with his head banging along the pavement
as they drove off
a murder black family draped over the
fence of their home
outside an only couple knelt by their
bed
praying to god with their heart and
their soul
when they were shot in the back of their
heads
private planes private planes dropping
explosives
the first and only domestic aerosol of
its kind
on an american city here in tulsa
eight of greenwood's nearly two dozen
churches burned like
mount zion across the street had burned
an ame
mother randall said it was like a war
mother fletcher says all these years
later she
still sees black bodies around
the greenwood newspaper publisher a.j
smitherton
smitherman penned a poem
of what he heard and felt that night
and here's the poem he said kill them
burn them
set the pace teach them how to keep
their place
i should have predicted but we're
banning so many people for racism in the
chat it's really crazy
that's what he remembers in the poem
that he wrote
100 years ago at this hour
on this first day of june smoke
darkened the tulsa sky
rising from 35 blocks of greenwood
that were left in ash and ember raised
in rubble
less than 24 hours in less than 24 hours
1 hundred black homes and businesses
were lost
insurance companies they had insurance
many of them
rejected claims of damage
ten thousand people were left destitute
and homeless
placing internment camps as i was told
today
they were told don't you mention you
were ever in a camp
or we'll come and get you that's a
survivor's story
yet no one no arrests
of the mob were made none
no proper accounting of the dead
the death toll records by local
officials said there were
36 people that's all
36 people based on studies
records and accounts the likelihood
the likely number is much more in the
multiple of hundreds
untold bodies dumped into mass graves
families who at a time waited for
hours and days to know the fate of their
loved ones
are now descendants
who have gone 100 years without cloture
but you know as we speak
the process the process of exhuming
the unmarked graves has started
and at this moment i'd like to pause
for a moment of silence for the fathers
the mothers the sisters sons and
daughters
friends of god and greenwood
wow they deserve the dignity and they
deserve our respect
may their souls rest in peace
my fellow americans this was not a riot
this was a massacre
among among the worst in our history
but not the only one
and for too long forgotten by our
history
as soon as it happened there was a clear
effort
to erase it from our memory our
collective memories
from the news and everyday conversations
for a long time schools in tulsa didn't
even teach it
let alone schools elsewhere and most
people didn't realize that a century ago
the second ku klux klan had been founded
the second ku klux kennedy founded a
friend of mine john meacham
i'd written when i said i was running to
restore the soul of america
he wrote a book called the soul america
not because of what i said
there's a picture about page 160 in the
book
showing over 30 000 klu klux klan
members
in full regalia reverend pointed hats
the robes
marching down pennsylvania avenue in
washington dc jesse you know all about
this
washington washington dc if my memory is
correct there were 37
members of the house of representatives
who were open members of the clan
there were five if i'm not mistaken you
could have said it was five
members of the united states senate open
members of the klan
multiple governors were open
members of the klan
most people didn't realize that a
century ago the clan
was founded just six years before the
horrific destruction here in tulsa
and one of the reasons why it was
founded
was because of guys like me are catholic
it wasn't about african-americans then
it was about making sure that all those
polish
and irish and italian and eastern
european catholics who came to the
united states after world war one
would not pollute christianity right
remember that a lot of these things
are really protestant white movements
protestant
so so a lot of catholics were they were
bad and not under that paradigm millions
of white americans belonged to the klan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
and that hate became embedded
systematically and systematically in our
laws and our culture we do ourselves no
favors by pretending none of this
ever happened or doesn't impact
us today because it does still impact us
today
we can't just choose to learn what we
want to know
and not what we should know
[Music]
you should know the good
the bad everything
that's what great nations do they come
to
terms
with their dark sides and we're a great
nation
the only way to build a common ground is
to truly repair and to rebuild
i come here to help fill the silence
because in silence wounds deepen
and only as painful as this only in
remembrance
do wounds heal we just have to choose to
remember
[Music]
we memorialize what happened here in
tulsa so it can be
so it can't be erased we know here
in this hallowed place we simply can't
bury
pain and trauma forever and at some
point
there'll be a reckoning an inflection
point like we're facing right now as a
nation
what many people hadn't seen before or
or
simply refused to see cannot be ignored
any longer
you see it in so many places
there's greater recognition that for too
long
we've allowed a narrowed cramped view
of the promise of this nation to fester
the view that america is a zero-sum game
where there's only one winner if you
succeed
i fail if you get ahead
i'm fall behind if you get a job
i lose mine and maybe worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself
[Music]
up
instead of if you do well we all do well
right we see that in greenwood
this story about the loss of life but a
loss of living
of wealth and posterity and
possibilities
that still reverberates today mother
fletcher talks about how she was the
only able to attend school in the fourth
grade
and eventually found work in the
shipyards as a domestic worker
mr van ellis has shared how even after
enlisting and serving in world war
ii he still came home to struggle with a
segregated america
imagine all those hotels and dinners and
mom
and pop shops that could
have been passed down this past hundred
years
imagine what could have been done for
black families in greenwood
financial security and generational
wealth
if you come from backlines like my my
family working-class middle-class
families
the only way we ever able to generate
any wealth
was inequity in our homes imagine what
they contributed then
what they could have contributed all
these years
imagine a thriving greenwood in north
tulsa for the last 100 years
but that would have meant for all of
tulsa including the white community
well the people of green would rebuild
again in the years after the massacre
it didn't last eventually neighborhoods
were redlined on maps
[Music]
locking black tulsa out of home
ownerships
the highway was built right through the
heart of the community
i was talking about our west side what
95 did after
we were occupied by the military after
dr king was
murdered the community cutting off black
families and businesses from jobs and
opportunity
chronic underinvestment from state and
federal governments denied greenwood
even just a chance of rebuilding this
we must find the courage to change the
things we know
we can change that's what vice president
harris and i are focused on
along with our entire administration
including our housing urban development
secretary
marcia fudge who's here today
yeah shouldn't he be ranting about
flushing toilets or heat or
air conditioning or something soon it's
weird not to hear that
because today we're announcing two
expanded efforts
targeted toward black wealth creation
that will also help
the entire community the first is my
administration has launched an
aggressive effort to combat racial
discrimination and housing
that includes everything from redlining
to the cruel fact that a home owned by a
black family
is too often appraised at lower value
than a similar home
owned by a white man right
and i might add and i need help if you
haven't answered this when i can't
figure this one out
congressman horsford but if you live in
a black community
and there's another one on the other
side of the highway it's a white
community it's
built by the same builder and you have a
better driving record than the guy with
the same car
in the white community you're getting
paid more for your auto insurance
shockingly the percentage of black
american home ownership
is lower today in america
than when the fair housing act was
passed more than 50 years ago
lower today that's wrong
and we're committed to changing that
just imagine
if instead of denying millions of
americans the ability to own their own
home
and build generational wealth we made it
possible for them to buy a home and
build
equity into that into that home and
provide for their families
second small businesses are the engines
of our economy and the glue of our
communities
that as president my administration
oversees hundreds of billions of dollars
in federal contracts
for everything from refurbishing decks
of aircraft carriers or installing
railings in
federal buildings to professional
services
we have a thing called i won't go into
it at all there's not enough time now
but
i'm determined to use every taxpayer's
dollar that is assigned to me to spend
going to american companies and american
workers
to build that build american products
and as part of that
i'm going to increase the share of the
dollars the federal government spends
to small disadvantaged businesses
including black and brown small
businesses
right now it calls for 10 i'm going to
move that to 15 percent of every dollar
spent
i decided to do that
just imagine instead of denying millions
of entrepreneurs
the ability to access capital and and
contracting
made it possible to take their dreams to
the marketplace to create jobs and
invest in our communities
that the data shows young black
entrepreneurs are just as capable of
succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
instead of
consigning millions of american children
to under-resourced schools
let's teach each and every child three
and four years old
access to school not day care school
[Music]
in the last 10 years studies have been
done by all the great universities
it shows that are increased by 56
percent the possibility of a child no
matter what background they come from
no matter what if they start school at
three years old
they have a 56 percent chance of going
all through all 12
years without any trouble and being able
to do well
and a chance to learn and grow and
thrive in a school
and throughout their lives and let's
unlock
more than an incredible creativity and
innovation that will come
from the nation's historically backed
colleges universities
[Music]
i have a 5 billion year program giving
them the resources to invest
in research centers and laboratories and
high demand fields
to compete for good paying jobs in
industries like of the future like cyber
security
the reason why they don't their their
students are equally able to learn as
well
and get the good paying job to start at
90 and 100 000 bucks
but they don't have they don't have the
back they don't have the money
to provide and build those laboratories
so guess what
they're going to get the money to build
those rights
so instead of just talking about
infrastructure what's good about
the uh about the business of actually
rebuilding roads and highways
filling the sidewalks and cracks
installing street lights and high-speed
internet
creating space space to live and work
and play
safely let's ensure access to health
care clean water
clean air nearby grocery stores stocked
with fresh
vegetables and food that they in fact
deal with i mean
these are all things we can do does
anyone doubt
this whole nation will be better off
with these investments
the rich will be just as well off the
middle class will do better and
everybody will do better
it's about good paying jobs financial
stability
and being able to build some
generational wealth it's about economic
growth for our
country and out-competing the rest of
the world which is now
out-competing us but just as fundamental
as any of these investments i've
discussed
[Music]
this may be the most fundamental the
right
to vote the right to vote
[Music]
a lot of the members of the black caucus
knew john lewis better night but i knew
him
on his deathbed like many i called john
to speak to him
rev all john wanted to do is talk about
how i was doing
he died i think about 25 hours later
but you know what john said he called
the right to vote precious
almost sacred he said the most powerful
non-violent tool we have in a democratic
society
this second right is under assault with
incredible intensity like i've never
seen
even though i got started as a public
defender and a civil rights lawyer
with an intensity and aggressiveness
we've not seen in a long long time
it's simply unamerican it's not however
sadly unprecedented the creed
we shall overcome there's a long time
mainstay of the civil rights movement
jesse jackson can tell you better than
anybody
the obstacle to process to progress
that have to be overcome are a constant
challenge
we saw it in the 60s over the current
assault
is not just an echo of a distant history
in 2020 we faced a tireless assault on
the right to vote
restrictive laws lawsuits threats to of
intimidation
voter purges and more we resolved to
overcome it all
we did more americans voted in the last
election than
any in the midst of a pandemic than any
election in american
history not even close really
you got voters registered you got voters
to the polls
the rule of law held democracy prevailed
we overcame
but today let me be unequivocal right
i've been engaged in this work my whole
career
and we're going to be ramping up our
efforts to overcome again
i will have more to say about this at a
later date to truly unprecedented
assault on our democracy
an effort to replace nonpartisan
election administrators
and to intimidate those charged with
tallying and reporting the election
results but today
as for the act of voting itself i urge
voting rights groups in this country to
begin to redouble their efforts
now to register and educate voters and
in june
[Music]
in june should be a month of action on
capitol hill
i hear all the folks on tv saying why
doesn't biden get this done
well because biden only has a majority
of effectively four votes in the house
and a
tie in the senate with two members of
the senate who vote
more with my republican friend
but we're not giving up there's a call
out representative passed for the people
act to protect our democracy the senate
will take it up later this month and i'm
going to fight like heck
with every tool in my disposal for his
passage
the house is also working in the john
lewis voting rights act which is
which is critical to providing new legal
tools
to combat the new assault on the right
to vote
to signify the importance of our efforts
today i'm asking vice president harris
to help these efforts and lead them
among her many other responsibilities
with her leadership
and your support we're going to overcome
again i promise you
but it's going to take a hell of a lot
of work and finally
we have to and finally we must address
what remains the stain
on the sole america what happened in
greenwood was an act of hate and
domestic terrorism
with the through line that exists today
still
just close your eyes and remember what
you saw in charlottesville
four years ago on television uh-oh
neo-nazis
white supremacist the kkk
coming out of those fields at night
virginia with lighted torches
the veins bulging on their as they were
screaming remember just close your eyes
and picture what it was
well mother fletcher said when she saw
the insurrection at the capitol
on january the 9th it broke her heart
a mob of violent white extremists thugs
said reminded her of what happened here
in greenwood 100 years ago
look around the various hate crimes
against asian americans and jewish
americans
hate that never goes away hate only
hides
jesse i think i mentioned this to you i
thought after you guys
pushed through with dr king the voting
rights act and
the civil rights act i thought we were
moved
what i didn't realize i thought we made
enormous progress i was so proud to be a
little part of it
but you know what rev i didn't realize
hates never defeated it only hides right
it hides and given a little bit of
oxygen
just a little bit of oxygen buys leaders
it comes out of there on from under the
rock like it was happening
again as if it never went away
so folks we can't we must not give hate
a safe harbor
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according to the
intelligence community terrorism from
white supremacy
is the most lethal threat to the
homeland today
wow not isis not al-qaeda
white supremacists wow that's not me
that's the intelligence community under
both
trump and under my administration two
weeks ago that'll be called racist by
republicans over 19 hate crimes act
which the house had passed in the senate
my administration will soon lay out our
broader strategy to counter domestic
terrorism
and the violence driven by the most
heinous hate crimes
and other forms of vigority of bigotry
but i'm going to close where i started
please to mother randall
mother fletcher mr van ellis to the
descendants and
all survivors thank you
thank you for giving me the honor of
being able to spend some time with you
earlier today thank you for your courage
thank you for your commitment and thank
your children
your grandchildren and your uncle and
your nieces and your nephews
to see and learn from you is a gift
a genuine gift dr john hope franklin
one of america's greatest historians
tulsa's proud son whose father was a
green wood survivor said and i quote
whatever you do it must be done in the
spirit of good will and mutual respect
and even love how else
can we overcome the past and be worthy
of our forebearers and face the future
comp with confidence and with hope
[Music]
on this sacred and solemn day may we
find that distinctly greenwood spirit
that defines the american spirit
the spirit that gives me so much
confidence and hope for the future
that helps us see face to face a spirit
that helps us know fully who we are and
who we can be
as a people and as a nation
i've never been more optimistic about
the future than i am today
i mean that the reason is
because of this new generation of young
people
they're the best educated they're the
least prejudiced
the most open generation in american
history
and although i have no scientific basis
i'm about to say
but those of you who are over 50 how
often did you ever see
how often do you ever see advertisements
on television with black and white
couples
not a joke i challenge you
find today when you turn on the stations
sit on one station for two hours
and i don't know how many commercials
you'll see lay eight to five
two to three out of five have mixed race
couples in them
that's not by accident they're selling
soap man
not a joke before pat goodell used to
say you want to know what's happening in
american culture
watch advertising because they want to
sell what they have
we have hope and folks like you honey
there is another interpretation of that
but
we have hope but we've got to give them
support
we have got to give them the backbone
to do what we know has to be done
because i doubt whether any of you would
be here if you didn't care
deeply about this you sure and the devil
didn't come to hear me speak
but i really mean it i really mean it
let's not give up man let's not give up
as the old saying goes hope springs
eternal
i know we've talked a lot about famous
people but i'm uh my colleagues in the
senate used to always kid me because i
was always quoting irish poets
they think i did it because i'm irish
they think i did it because as we irish
we have a little chip on our shoulder
a little bit sometimes that's how i did
it i did it because they're the best
poets in the world
right you can smile it's okay it's true
there's a famous poet who wrote a poem
called the curet troy
sheamus and there's a stance in it i
think
is the definition what i think should be
our call today for young people
he said history teaches us not to hope
on this side of the grave but then
[Music]
once in a lifetime that long forward
tidal wave of justice rises up
and hope and history rhyme
let's make it rhyme
there is president joe biden in tulsa
oklahoma
a very solid speech
and a lot going on there now a lot of
interesting reactions first
i it is strange not to hear anything
about plumbing i mean as we've become
used to it and marjorie taylor pacman
sends a super chat saying overall good
but
disappointed he didn't discuss elements
of bathrooms very strongly he also
ignored
the eyesore windmills and forest
management i know it's like we've got
it just doesn't feel like a presidential
speech if you're not mentioning flushing
a toilet 15 times
we've all become accustomed to it now
more seriously edward tyler says
maybe it's just me but i don't
understand how people in this day and
age can still be racist there are so
many problems that are so much bigger
than where someone comes from or what
color of the skin that's exactly why
we see that that's part of it when when
the real problems that have to be solved
depend on so many different things and
we're looking at a combination of
complex geopolitics and the eroding of
natural resources and the irreversible
impact we're having on the planet
and the fact that the rich in
corporations have disproportionate
control over our election systems
the problem must be black people
committing crime
and brown people taking our jobs it's
because it's simple and because the real
problems are complicated that's exactly
why
you continue to see it right that's what
uh i
i think um it's it's backwards you're
right my view is yours
with everything we're up against we're
still doing racism and xenophobia and
all this different stuff
but that's exactly why because people
would love to have something
simple to blame than actually seriously
deal with
uh the issues that we have to deal with
um okay so quite an event
quite an event and uh i thought it was
uh overall a very very good speech
i do want to say i'm sorry i missed so
many people
louis alvarado signed up on my website
with the coupon code
memorial21 richard vendetti
signed up with the code logan butcher
taking advantage of the discount
tom mcdowell using the coupon code
felony21 on my website that's dangerous
friendly friendly branched um
using the coupon code really appreciate
everybody there
as well as all the great twitch
subscribers necro necrofix and bit101
what the spock
and all of these folks remember that the
second channel is
live you can find it at davidpakman.com
pacman live look at that little bump we
just got now
do people want me to preview what the
garden looks like today
i've not shown you my garden for weeks
everything is robe most things are
robust my
chard isn't looking good we're going to
be publishing that to the new
youtube channel soon but do people want
to see what is going on
um i last time i showed my garden i got
an angry email from someone saying
don't you dare show us your stinkweeds
people want to see it all right let's
take a look at it
uh let me get this set up here hold on
hold on a second i've gotta make sure
everything is looking right a full
garden tour will soon be published to
the new
youtube channel that's n-u-u
new but let's take a look at this one
um let me do slow motion
speed slower so first of all just to
start with
my swiss chart is dying that's the swiss
chard on the right
i'm just gonna have to pull them my
pepper plant is still looking good but
the swiss chard
it's just not working okay and it's been
raining a lot
but the uh this pepper plant is looking
good there's actually already some nubs
on it half the people are saying it
needs more rain half people saying it
there's too much rain listen guys
it's just gonna be what it is okay it's
just gonna be what it is the pepper
plant is looking strong
here's my gourmet purple lettuce
actually two types of lettuce there's
these leaves and then there's this kind
of stuff down here
it's beautifully producing salads
tremendous really really good salads
so that's a great stuff look at my mint
it's going and going and going i haven't
touched this mint is a perennial
it came back on its own these fuzzy
leaves are one
species i thought i wasn't getting my
other kind back but down here you're
starting to see the
non-fuzzy leaves grow back and the mint
is just by the end of the season this
thing is just
green everywhere green everywhere
beautiful mint
i think i've got peppermint and
spearmint and everything look at that
just really strong my genovese basil
looking nice here's another tomato plant
now i did send a message to kevin at
epic gardening saying i've got this
tomato plant it's got two main stems
do i need to cut a main stem do i at
some point
need to go one way or the other and just
say
here's the main stem and we've got to
cut it
or can they both grow in parallel a
little more genovese basil here looking
nice look at by the way the new growth
if you compare this to my original video
where i had maybe like two or three sets
of leaves
this is just going it's going great
um here's my flat leaf parsley here's
another tomato plant my sun golds
some of the leaves are not looking great
see how those there's a little bit of
what some might call disease on these
lower leaves
i could just cut them again it's a two
stem situation
i've been pulling the suckers do i need
to cut one of those
here's my big tomato plant and as you
can see
i've really you know the those bottom
uh these bottom eight or so inches
i've completely cleared and we're
already getting uh some nice flowers
here
tomatoes are going to be forming soon
we've pulled all the suckers
so there you see some flowers gonna have
some tomatoes soon
beautiful beautiful here are my cukes
i planted the cukes late so they're
really really small still
small cukes i'd love big cukes but
they're small
um i'm starting to they're starting to
go up the trellis as you can see
i don't know what we're gonna get there
look at these snap peas
now this is something else i've got four
of these they are beautiful
there's already here's one green pea see
snap pea i forget what these even are
here's one here's a second one here's a
third one all these flowers they're
beautifully climbing the one thing i'm
worried about is down near the soil it's
turning a little yellow this happened
last year with my zooks
but these i think are going to be nice
that's going to be really nice
here's another pepper plant we've got
some pepper nubs here you can already
see that's looking pretty good
here's one more tomato plant we've got a
few flowers going there
those will soon be tomatoes one more
pepper plant with a couple more nubs
if you're gonna write to me and say
david sir these are too close together
just skip it i know guys i know we'll
just see what happens okay
everybody relax little nub there that
i'm pointing out beautiful
this is my greek oregano it's just on
fire it's like a clown wig
quite frankly um that came back on its
own and it's fantastic
here are my japanese eggplants the one
on the right was planted earlier than
the one on the left
they never look great but they just keep
growing
they just keep growing so we'll see if
we get some japanese eggplants
here's my cilantro very nice or
coriander as some of our british
indian and other friends will say
here is my italian oregano again it's
like a clown wig
it's just gigantic it's got to be we've
already made pesto
here's my english time again looking
almost perfect
and this is the star this is my second
year
um strawberry plant already pulled three
strawberries
look at the size of those strawberries
and they are everywhere
there you just you look under a leaf and
you find five strawberries
the second plant it's just berries and
look like there's a little tucked away
here's another one
it's just incredible
it's great stuff and i don't know if you
noticed by the way let me see where this
is right here this is another runner
this right here is a new strawberry
plant it's the roots are in
and next year this will probably be full
bush
um it's just it's trying to escape
it's trying to escape so that's going on
and it's all looking pretty good and
look sixteen hundred uh
new milestone sixteen hundred
subscribers on the new youtube channel
pacman live where i'll have a more
detailed walk through of the garden so
guys a lot happening a lot happening and
extremely
extremely exciting big thank you to
trevor hufford
i appreciate trevor just signed up on my
website with the coupon code memorial21
and is new member number 28. alright so
very exciting everything that's
happening garden updates and all sorts
of other things coming very soon
thank you for joining me on this very
important
hundredth whoa hold on oh
everything going wrong here was the
speech joe biden delivering a speech
on the 100th anniversary the centennial
of the tulsa massacre we will be back
very soon
full gnome chomsky interview live on
youtube
in three hours okay we will see you then
you